hello folks
welcome to rational science
and i hope everybody can hear me if
someone would confirm that i would
really appreciate it
oh wait a minute here i started early
today because i had problems last time
transmitting so i'll see if
maybe
someone can confirm
thank you
thank you appreciate that well first of
all i got to start with an apology today
okay
i'm going to apologize for not being
here on sunday
i was in here on sunday because i was
sick
and i have uh
some
respiratory problems i've got bronchitis
chronic bronchitis
and
i i think um
uh close to having uh you know asthma or
something that's what they diagnosed so
i should be here today but the show must
go on
okay
uh yeah and terrible weather in this
area so i i didn't start my vacation
very well okay so if i start coughing
you know what's what's happening okay
anyways i'm going to start by saying
that you know in this site
we say that we're due for extinction
humans are due for extinction
okay and uh why because my theory is
that
um
all animals die
when mother nature declares
that they should die it's all scheduled
and it's scheduled because of food
food does not last forever
for different types of animals when food
runs out the animals run out that's
known as a mass extinction
and what's going to run out for humans a
smart
all-knowing humans well
what's going to run out is food
and why is food going to run out because
we produce it and we distribute it
and we distribute it and produ produce
and distribute it only because
um
we grow it ourselves we produce our own
food unlike you know just about i think
every other animal we produce our own
food
we look ahead
and that's why we have so many billions
of people on earth we can produce all
this food we know how much to produce
and it all functions thanks to something
called money trade
exchange
okay we have this currency that we use
uh so that you exchange it for food
and so what happens when the exchange is
no longer valuable because the exchange
is only faith
you know in god we trust
and so we have this exchange this
abstraction that we use to buy food
for from people who produce it and they
produce it because they pay salaries
more more exchange to people who produce
it who actually produce it
and distribute it also because of this
exchange this money thingy okay and so
yeah if money happens to run out food
will run out most people on earth will
die some people will survive some cup
pockets here and there
but it will be for all effective
purposes the end of man that's the
theory okay
and uh you say well bill uh are we that
close i mean how close is this i can't
give you a date i'm just saying it's uh
maybe
a few months away maybe a few years away
uh but not too far into the future
that's my guess i'm not an astrologer
but that's the best uh rule of thumb or
general picture that i can give you i
don't think we're gonna last that long
okay
and here are some uh things that are
happening today that give you maybe an
indication that we're not too far away
from that point okay and here's uh the
first one it's uh from the international
business times
uh they talk about uh they talk about
ukraine war but
i just focused on a paragraph there the
market meltdown okay says on the
business agenda discussions are likely
to focus on the souring state of
financial markets and the global economy
after a sharp bounce back from the
downturn triggered two years ago by the
onset of the uh pandemic there are now
myriad threats to that recovery leading
the international monetary fund to
downgrade its global growth forecast for
the second time since the year began
inflation due
to hubble uh
supply chains emerged as a problem last
year particularly in the u.s economy and
that has been compounded since the
beginning of 2022 by events including
russians invasion of ukraine and waves
of cobit 19 lockdowns across china that
have stalled a recovery okay
so that's uh just a
you could say a just big picture
of what's going on okay
but um if you look at uh some of the
trends that we've had long-term trends
okay that's the issue here okay i think
you're gonna see that they're all
negative
and by negative i don't mean you know uh
bill you're so negative you're
you're so pessimistic it's not about
pessimism it's it's about uh realistic
you know what's happening what's really
actually happening out there you know
and and these are numbers that you can
follow for the last 50 years and they
they show the same trend so this is
something you can more or less put your
hat on you know you can you can bet your
life on this and here's uh one of the
trends and that's the trend of violence
okay uprisings in different parts of the
world okay
and it says uncertainty in the world
global uncertainty as measured by the
world uncertainty index they have one of
those remains high okay world uncensored
in index there you see it and they just
monitor that and you can see the picture
there people rioting everywhere okay
that's happening in many countries
across the world okay
in fact in every country i would say
okay
and then uh here you have something from
bloomberg okay it says uh a five
trillion dollar wealth sock is cracking
americans eggs nest eggs okay
it says outside wealth gains that worsen
inequality now in reverse housing
downturn seen having brother impact as
rates surge okay if you go through there
you see that it says the world's richest
nation is waking up to an unpleasant and
unfamiliar sensation it's getting poorer
okay
americans collective net worth has been
climbing at a dizzying rate for the past
two years even as families and
businesses contend with the ravages of
kobit 19. households piled up an extra
38.5 trillion from early 2020 to the end
of last year bringing their collective
net worth to a record 142 trillion the
federal reserve estimates
uh just as the
u.s is learning to live with the virus
and spending shifts
back
and spending shifts back in
toward pre-pandemic normals it faces a
new scary threat
a plunge in wealth
since the start of 2022 that jp morgan
estimates um totals at least five
trillion and could reach nine trillion
by year end
okay
so there are going to be problems with
um
with the economy okay and i'd like to
say that the only economy in the world
that needs to collapse is the us economy
because so many countries in the world
are clinging from the u.s economy
economy of the u.s falls we all fall
that's the way i look at it the u.s
economy cannot be allowed to fall too
big to fail okay
but i want to show you some numbers uh
long-term trends so that you get a
a picture that i can't be too much off
my rocker okay
here it is uh here's one okay
uh this is the estimate for potential
growth remained fairly low you can see
the trend since the 1960s
we're talking about 60 years here it's
been down okay it's going down and down
this is the potential real gdp growth
okay annual percent change the percent
change is dropping dropping dropping and
i have to believe that sometime it's
going to go to zero no matter what we do
we can stand on our heads it's going to
go to zero at some point and you say
well bill that's 60 years maybe we'll go
back up
well here's a longer trend and this is a
90 year trend since 1930 okay and you
can see that the picture is still
you know
downwards
even the long-term trend goes down down
down down down
meaning the rate of growth has been
declining overall uh in the last almost
100 years okay so what i'm saying is
that you know we cannot reverse this
trend there's nothing we can do to
make a country like the united states
grow back again
at a bigger rates like five six ten
percent there's no way we can do that
uh you know what we would have to do
maybe maybe a solution would be right
create new towns okay so people move to
these new towns hopefully young people
you know colonists
you know log cabins you know whatever
and they go to wyoming montana you know
the big
states
and they start founding new cities
and little towns you know villages turn
into cities turn into
megalopolis you know
that that might work so that you have an
increase in population you have
increased demand
and that you know um triggers the
economy to expand that that would help
something like that would help but i
don't think i can't even imagine
something like that happen
uh what are you gonna do have a gold
rush
you know to create that effect one
effect is one i'm quite familiar with is
that the united states creates prisons
federal prisons state prisons and uh
what happens when you install a prison
into into little towns and i've seen
that happen several times i think that
was part of the
plan of the federal government you
install a prison and immediately all
these services
come around the prison and it kind of
starts kick-starts the city the village
turns into a city or a town you know
that might work but you know you can't
put everybody in prison i mean there's
only so many prisoners all you can do is
increase the
sentencing guidelines
give them more time to keep them in
there for longer periods of time and
then you know have all these services
that uh come around the prison and start
feeding the prison but you know that's
uh kind of artificial um
i don't think it's gonna happen i don't
think that there's any way to increase
the population in little towns and turn
them into cities
villages to towns towns the city cities
to
big cities you know
whatever cities you see on the planet
today
i think that's what we're going to die
with okay so the big cities that you see
there i don't know
new york l.a
moscow london you know we're going to
die with those big cities and whatever
little towns there are out there
i think that's how the economy the
collapse of the economy is going to
catch us with whatever cities we have
today
okay uh you say united states well
there's another big economy in the world
fortunately because that's created some
demand in the last i would say at least
40 years okay and that's china but see
even china the gdp growth
went great until the 2000s it was
growing really fast okay up to 10
percent because china was a very very
backward country
and uh you know you had this opening up
between the united states and china even
though china was a communist country and
you had nixon who was a very
anti-communist individual and they they
shook hands anyways you know business is
business or like
who is it
coolidge once said the business of
america is
business
okay so we don't care about uh ideology
let's just do business and but you can
see it's been dropping ever since and so
the question is if china drops and
united states drops well who is there
left to uh pull on the
on the global economy will it be the
martians the klingons someone from outer
space
you know uh we're running down the clock
okay uh once we get to zero
zero growth uh gdp growth on the planet
we're gonna be all in trouble okay
and uh here you have another trend
manufacturing has been going down down
down okay over uh at least in the
industrialized nations some little
nations have picked up on a lot of this
uh manufacturing
but again manufacturing has become a
smaller percentage of the global economy
and parallel to that here you have the
rise in services
but the rise in services
again is very tricky because even though
there is a rise in services
uh at the expense of manufacturing and
agriculture what you have is that the
services you can see it there in that
last
sentence in that paragraph there says
u.s trade conflicts with china and the
eu and says and decreased demand for
traditional services due to
digitalization and
automation
okay so we have a different type of
services today no longer barbering or
i don't know landscaping or stuff like
that
the kind of services we have today are
internet services a lot of ads a lot of
entertainment
you know and you might say well that's
value
they use that word value like if we're
talking about something
value is faith it's just an opinion
you know we're not talking physics here
we're talking uh abstractions
which is the opposite of physical and
you know when you have a lot of internet
services and ads and commercials and so
on entertainment
that's not economics mother nature
doesn't understand that mother nature
understands food
okay
and you know food doesn't disappear
whatever you have in your cupboard
whatever you have in your fridge that's
there that's real okay uh your faith
or your entertainment because you
heard someone sing or someone dance or
whatever someone act
you know that mother nature doesn't
understand that okay love
mother nature doesn't understand that
either
no she understands food you need to feed
yourself to live one more day and when
food disappears because faith disappears
because you don't believe anymore in the
global economy you don't believe in the
dollar you'd rather have things or maybe
you buy stuff
you know um when you don't believe in
money anymore well then you have a
problem and why wouldn't you believe in
money i mean everybody believes in money
i mean if they give you money you would
accept it right they give you gold i
don't think you would have a problem
with that right
but the problem is gold is a rock and
money is maybe a piece of paper maybe an
abstraction like a you know a
crypto coin or whatever
and it's all faith it all comes down to
faith you accept the gold bar or the
gold coin
only because you can dispose of it later
on and buy something with it something
real and that's why you accept it
but what happens when um when the
salaries go down lower and lower and
lower people don't can't make it to the
end of the month okay because the rent
is too high proportional to their real
income right and food is high so it's
proportional to their real income and at
some point lots of people get
left out of the
um
mainstream okay when more and more of
those people are left out of the
mainstream then you have what what i
showed earlier
riots okay
people breaking cars you know uh windows
and so on
burning tires
and you have upheavals and at some point
you know you can't make it to the end of
the month and at that point people
there's no way to keep them down okay at
some point the system does collapse
that's my theory uh take it or leave it
i know a lot of people say no bill you
don't know anything about economics okay
mother nature's economics that's what i
do i don't do
chicago school of economics economics
okay i do mother nature's economics her
economics is food and that's what
took the lives of all past uh animals
that died in mass extinctions
okay
my ten cents worth
okay let's move on we have a fellow who
criticized my notion
of the scientific method can you believe
that
criticizing the scientific the real
scientific method okay
and uh so
here give me a second here let me remove
this
okay and so he's a what i call a science
critic okay and uh what he's gonna
complain about is he says um
that
you you
you can understand
physics right physics or physical
mechanisms or whatever you can
understand them but you don't have to be
able to visualize them
in other words he doesn't relate
understanding with visualization
okay
and i see more or less the opposite i'm
saying that
in physics
physics is about mechanisms
and if you cannot visualize it if you
cannot make a movie
of your mechanism
you did not understand it
okay so that's going to be the issue let
me put him on so that you can hear from
the horse's mouth okay give me a second
here and here goes listen carefully
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
if you cannot visualize a mechanism
have you understood it
so it's not really about visualizing it
it's about understanding it yes
visualizing it can help but it's not the
be-all end-all if you can't visualize
something but you can understand it then
that's more important than being able to
visualize it but not being able to
understand it
okay we got it uh that's the issue
before him today you know the subject
matter today and let's uh start with
what science is and what science is not
because that's i think where the problem
starts we have to go all the way down to
science and find out what is science
about yeah i think that's where the
issue is okay so here we go
science according to this site our
channel right um
is about explaining rationally and only
about explaining rationally what is the
definition we have
rational explanations
very simple very straightforward
not worthy
very concise
very
difficult to challenge because it's
concise
on the other hand what you have today uh
you know uh is this notion that people
have that of what science is or in their
minds okay what they think science is
they think it's about observing studying
uh running experiments making
predictions i forget to put in there you
know i just this just came out of the
top of my head you know the fact that
they use math and equations okay
that's got nothing to do with science
either we don't do why because math is
about describing math can only describe
an equation can only describe so that's
not part of science we explain we do not
describe anyone can describe a chair
okay not everyone can explain you know
how gravity works okay so that's where
you have to break your brains okay
voting for theories we do not have
democracy
in science we do not also have tradition
we don't say well that's the way we
always did it you know if it don't work
meaning a science explanation you cannot
explain then we have to change it we
have to do something about it it's
broken we have to fix what is broken
okay and we don't do winning prizes none
of that stuff okay so what is instead
science okay well there you have it and
uh here you have uh the mathematical
method mathematical method as we call it
this is what we inherited from the
people in the 17th so-called uh century
so-called scientific revolution
it's a which is really a method of
research and persuasion what they did is
include things on
how to do experiments in your little
dark basement you do research you do
study you put your brains to work no
problem there but then you know when you
have to come to the
conference what you have to do is
explain what you learned instead they
emphasize
and harp on
persuasion they said let me convince you
let me show you proof let me show you
evidence
no no that's not science okay and so
they have all these uh
steps in the so-called mathematical
method here you know
observe explain tentatively which they
call a hypothesis they do predictions
they do experiments they describe
mathematically you know and they call it
a theory which is not a theory theory is
an explanation not a description an
equation is not an explanation
okay they invent technology they think
that they with that they confirm the
theory they convince uh other
mathematicians they talk about truth
fact you know knowledge you know we know
you don't know we'd know okay and we
proved it through some experiment okay
and then they uh verify through
measurement in other words someone else
uh tries to verify your measurement
especially your description your
mathematical description and if they
confirm it uh well then they
were not able to falsify it there's no
falsification of your theory and as long
as it's not falsified well that means
that you can continue rolling and
believe it it's about belief
then they win prizes and then do the
celebrity circuit that's the that's
essentially the method today that they
have out there and now we're saying
that's not that's not science sciences
rational explanations specifically it's
as it's related to physics which is what
we do here okay so what is physics well
here we have it
this is a gives you an idea of what
physics is okay
uh well first
we have it here um those who have a
different version of this scientific
method the one that we propose rational
explanations well they have a single
recourse okay and that is uh to propose
a definition that they can defend
okay
and uh
so
they should be able to use it
consistently and then
if it's worth anything their scientific
method or their version of science they
should be able to explain how the
universe works the things we are
interested in explaining we want to know
how gravity works we want to know how
magnetism works
how light works how the atom works this
is what we and by how i don't mean
describe i mean explain the mechanism
what is the cause
that's what we're talking about okay and
if you're going to define it if you're
going to challenge the definition
rational
explanations right if you're going to
challenge that definition well uh
you know the more things that you add to
your definition if you make it you know
a big paragraph 200 words
500 words right the more words you put
in there the easier it will be to
destroy your notion of science
okay because you will not be able to
apply it consistently the more
predicates you include in there okay
so uh that's something you gotta keep in
mind if you're gonna challenge the
definition and here is um
uh you know the the version we have
today
uh of science it says uh there is
currently no consensus regarding the
definition of life this is an example of
why you know you need you can't put too
many predicates in there because it's
easier to tear down and i'm giving you
an example here in the word life okay
nobody has been able to define the world
life in other words no biologist on
planet earth has any clue how to define
the word life okay they never define the
word but they're all biologists which is
the study of life according to them okay
and so you have one popular definition
this comes from the wikipedia is that
organisms are open systems that what
that maintain homeostasis
are composed of cells have a life cycle
undergo metabolism can grow adapt to
their environment respond to stimuli
reproduce evolve etc right okay great
okay so it says there for example uh um
let's see let me pick one out of here
uh reproduce for example well my
grandmother doesn't reproduce uh anymore
my aunt never reproduce were they alive
okay
can grow what if you don't grow anymore
what if you shrink
uh does that mean that you're you're not
alive
so you can see how easy it is to tear
this definition down because they put so
many predicates and so many conditions
for defining the word life and that's
the problem when you define the word um
science the more words you put in there
the tougher it's going to be for you to
defend that definition because you're
going to have to be able to apply each
one of those predicates
each one of those conditions each one of
those specifications
to whatever challenge you receive
okay so that's why you know all my
definitions are
very short
it makes it hard for someone to attack
it and it's got to contain the essence
in fact all definitions should be that
form the foundations of science of
physics of philosophy have to be very
very short as short as you can make them
get rid of words the more words you put
in there the easier it's gonna be to
tear down okay that's my
rule of thumb for you okay take it or
leave it okay
and here we have the word physics okay
which we want to define this is what we
do here okay
uh science is divided into two
categories and one of those and only two
categories okay one is physics and the
other one's philosophy okay we're gonna
deal a little bit with philosophy today
because we have this uh issue of um
the
multi-universe of the universe okay
and so what is physics physics the
branch of science that attempts to
explain mechanisms rationally
rational explanations of
what of mechanisms that's physics
and philosophy is rational explanations
of behaviors in comparison okay
uh and specifically gravitational
electromagnetic phenomena that's what we
want to explain that's what remains out
there we we've been able to explain
everything we can see and touch
that we're more or less in familiar with
we have not been able to explain in the
last 3000 years
that which we cannot see that which we
cannot touch that's where the problem is
they have not been able to answer that
and what they do is do a lot of math and
then they give you an irrational
explanation and then they say well
that's not important anyways that's just
philosophy opinion
and that's what they call science that
they gave you a descript a mathematical
description in lieu of an explanation
okay and so again the more predicates
you introduce
the worse it's going to be for you if
you're going to define the word physics
okay so we say rational explanations of
mechanisms that's very short how do they
define it i think i have it here this
definition of from the wikipedia okay
physics is the natural sciences studies
matter it's fundamental constituents
it's motion and behavior through space
and time and the related entities of
energy and force okay so you can see
a quite lengthy definition or notion
that they have today
and what's the problem with it well
energy emotion and force are concepts
uh physics does not study concepts
that's probably where it all falls apart
but
it talks about
you know actually they're referring to
uh descriptions but they say it's
studies no physics doesn't study
anything you could be studying anything
you want okay and that doesn't mean
you're going to learn that doesn't mean
you know you understand something okay
so studying is not enough even children
study
does is a child who studies in
kindergarten is he or she is
a scientist because she studies
so studies alone does not do the trick
you can study all you want when you come
to the conference we want you to explain
what you
understood what you learned you know
share with us your intelligence but if
you just say i studied and then you got
a zero on the test well what was the
point of study i mean prove that you
studied
and the way you prove it is by
explaining
so no to say that you studied and it
says studies matter
okay so you studied matter what did you
learn
fundamental constituents okay what are
the fundamental constituents space-time
is that a fundamental constituent energy
mass force time are those fundamental
constituents of you know the universe
and then it says it's motion yeah we do
uh try to explain motion but uh motion
of things that we can see is no problem
the question is motion of that which we
cannot see and touch okay that's where
it falls apart again okay and again
behavior through space and time again we
don't go through space or time because
neither time or space are physical
mechanisms they're not
containers they're not media okay so you
cannot say that you go through space or
you go through time okay so whatever
through
means in there in this
context here now we don't we don't go
through space or through time you can't
say you go through space or through time
not in physics maybe in some kind of
religion out there mathematics you know
then you can talk about going through
space and time
okay so um um
you know here uh here we have a case uh
for this gentleman who says uh that um
a mechanism you do not have to visualize
it you can just understand it
and we can say no you
you
if if you cannot visualize it you did
not understand the mechanism
and as for a fellow he doesn't
understand that okay so here we go let's
give give him an example i'm gonna show
you
something that happened okay it's gonna
be uh window breaks
very simple stuff okay
and i'm gonna show you that first okay
here it goes we have something going
through the window it's known as a
horseshoe
and here we have a
good old felix the cat he revolves it
and throws this horseshoe okay so you
can see how it broke okay so if you ask
anybody okay what did you just see there
and they would say how did the window
break
well how did the uh
glass end up on the floor well i think
everybody would say the same thing say
well there was a horseshoe thrown and
hit the window and broke it very simple
okay
okay now what if we do it this way okay
here we have it
and um
and this guy just waves his arm
did you see what broke it
can you tell me exactly how the window
broke now now that you cannot see
the mediators okay all you see is a guy
waving his arm okay and then the window
suddenly breaks like by magic remote
control
so how do the mathematicians do it well
they say they give you a description
they say something like this
okay they say that you get this force
that goes through the window okay they
use all these mathematical concepts so
they say look he he waved the mass
okay and
with all this energy right and the force
went through the window that's the kind
of answer you get from a mathematician
well so far you you have no ex no
physical interpretation for how the
window broke you cannot use these words
to explain how the window broke the way
you say it is you say a horse you went
through the window okay and we do not
need to know the resistance of the glass
none of that nonsense that people get
into we just need to know how the window
broke and it's very simple the mechanism
is horseshoe went through window period
tarzan light okay that's how you explain
that and you do not use these words as
mass energy or force okay
let me give you another example okay
just so we know that you have to explain
if you're going to explain a mechanism
you have to put objects in front of the
eyes
so you should be able to illustrate it
the language of physics is not
mathematics mathematics you know energy
mass force all that time you know that
nonsense the language of physics is
illustration you should have objects in
front of my eyes so that i can see the
mechanism and just by watching the the
entire show there i can get an idea of
how the window broke or whatever
whatever mechanism you're trying to
explain okay that's the point so you
should be able to illustrate you should
be able to visualize the mechanism in
order to say that you understood it
otherwise you can't say well i can't
visualize it but i understood it
now you're lying
you're you're kidding or you're fooling
yourself you thought you understood it
you can't visualize it the mechanism you
have not understood it in physic you
need to visualize okay and so here's
another example okay and here we have it
we have a pulley okay and it's pulling
on a box very simple stuff okay so you
ask how did the box go up very simple
stuff okay and you say okay someone
pulled on the rope and that was wound
around the pulley and that's what and
which was also tied to the box and you
know that's how the box went up we can
all explain how the box went up because
it's all connected
okay now let's do it uh the invisible
way okay suddenly the box goes up
okay and you say well how did the box go
up was it magic
i mean you know
now we don't see the mediator which in
this case was the rope right and
suddenly the box goes up and it's very
scary because you cannot explain it why
because you cannot see or touch whatever
is pulling the box up
how do the mathematicians do it well
this is the way they do it over there
they say well there's this mass and
there's a force that's maybe pushing it
from below because they don't see
anything there and say there's so much
energy involved okay
and uh it went up in so much time
okay so far we haven't answered the
question what is the physical mechanism
and so you say well you know i cannot
visualize it i cannot make a movie of it
all i can do is uh describe it with all
these mathematical terms there's so much
force and they give you a number
followed by a unit there's so much mass
number followed by a unit so much energy
number followed by unit so much time
numbers followed by a unit that's what
they give you and they say well yeah
yeah there's a force pushing up the mass
with so much energy and it took so much
time that's the kind of answer you get
and you say what's the mechanism how did
the box go up what what caused the box
to go up and they have no answer for
that okay
and uh
so yeah so the question is what's the
mechanism and so they say well maybe it
was warped space the workspace pulls it
down or wiped time you know usually it's
warp time okay they pulled it down
and so the box is pulling against it and
you still don't know what's pulling it
against the warp space
yeah
why is what's causing the box to go
against warp space
you still have no mechanism for what's
pulling the box up
and so yeah unless you can illustrate
the mechanism okay you you you have not
understood it all you can do is describe
it and say uh
mathematically in this case you say well
there's so much energy so much force so
much mass so much time or whatever other
parameter you want to put in there but
you have not been able to explain it
so this fellow says that yeah you know
you can you can um understand it uh
but not be able to visualize the
mechanism and the answer is
no
if you cannot make a movie of your
theory of your mechanism in physics
you have not
understood it you have to put physical
objects in physics physics first and
foremost is
uh you need an object you can't do
physics without an object you need
something there for that you need to
find the word object which is the
subject that leads to
the subject of today which is
uh the multiverse okay but in order to
get to the multiverse we have to start
somewhere else
okay
the multiverse is a
theory
or maybe it's more like an assumption
okay it's really a hypothesis which we
call an assumption it's a synonym of an
assumption and what is the assumption
the assumption is that there is more
than one universe out there
okay
why is that
significant in the in the case of
physics well because
you have to define the key words there
okay you have to define what is the word
universe what is an object which we more
or less just covered you need to have
objects in physics and you need to
define also the key word i think in
there which is the word space
okay
we need to know what space is what is
this thingy called space okay that's
that's essentially the gonna be the
issue today okay so we start with a
fellow who made a comment today
and so i'm going to put his comment up
there okay yeah
i'm sorry i'm going to start with
philosophy here first uh we have to
distinguish philosophy from physics okay
and why is this philosophy this part
well because philosophy deals primarily
with concepts and the problem that we
have with concepts is that you know
people
have no idea what a concept is
they have this vague notion from
ordinary speech
and
they introduce it into
physical
interpretations into physics okay and
the main concept again is this thing
called space which is a synonym of
nothing
space is nothing they're both the same
word okay you can you don't have to use
the word space you can use the word
nothing
but what is nothing well for that you
need to know what something is an object
a thing
and uh so you know you have to define
something and then you have to define
nothing and then they are hopefully
there are they are antonyms okay so
they're opposites okay so that you can
use them consistently also okay and so
because we're going to be dealing with
uh the multi-universe and the question
is
uh what separates one universe from
another that's going to be the key issue
okay so i start with philosophy here one
thought put a comment there says
philosophy should be at least two
should use at these two basic axioms he
says it's a way of thinking okay that's
what he thinks philosophy is the problem
there again is you know um how many ways
of thinking do we have on earth like
eight billion
everybody's a philosopher if that's the
definition
if we if philosophy is a way of thinking
then everybody has a way of thinking we
have eight billion uh philosophers on
earth and so the question there is
what's the difference between aristotle
and plato and the rest of humanity we
call them oh he's a greek philosopher
so what was different from him he had a
way of thinking
you know i mean
what's the difference we're all
philosophers that
so it has no meaning if you just say
that it's a way of thinking that's not a
definition we can use in any way shape
or form and to make it worse he says
philosophy should uh use at least two
basic uh axioms the law of identity and
the law of self-contradiction
and you look them up and they say law of
identity each thing is identical with
itself
a is equal to a
i mean how much idiocy can a person say
that a is equal to a
and so let's go to the law of uh
self-contradiction or
it's uh
the
law of contradiction is he he said it as
self-contradiction but it's
i looked it up it says there's no such
thing as self-contradict of law
self-contradiction but same thing the
point is that there's an example more
than a definition a cannot be both b and
not b at the same time
so uh law of identity a a and law of
self-contradiction a naughty hopi
great
that's it
it's this kind of idiocy
that is out there
what is
idiotic it's uh comes from big ideas you
know it's not a little ideas id art okay
so we call them idiots okay so anyone
who has this kind of nonsense this
garbage that has no place in science no
place in anything
this this is for a loony asylum
you know i mean what is this
what do we do with this
this is garbage
another vowel that says philosophy is
the search for truth
what is truth
well truth is a belief it's a it's an
opinion what is true to you is a lie to
me
and i'll prove that truth to you okay
very simple
uh give me any fact any truth any
anything that you want anything at all
anything at all you might say does god
exist i say no okay or you say yes i say
no i say yes and you say no
no matter what you say i'll say the
opposite
okay i won't agree with you so you say
okay
how about pi the number pi you know
that's that's a fact and i say no it
ain't
and you say no let me prove it to you
and you do all these examples tests
experiments whatever you want and i say
no no no no no
i don't believe you i don't accept
so what is true to you
will always be false to me because i
just want to play devil's advocate no
matter what no matter what you say i
don't care i'll take the opposite point
of view
so what do you do
okay so this is the issue the issue is
truth is an opinion
always and there's no such thing as fact
no such thing as truth all those are
opinions and nothing but
okay so let's keep that in mind
and
so
here we go with this this is the uh
scientific version of philosophy
okay and science is what rational
explanations very simple very
straightforward physics rational
explanations of mechanisms right causes
and mechanisms
and philosophy rational explanations of
behaviors okay reasons and purposes
that's essentially the difference now we
have a definition that you can say okay
now we know what philosophy is for the
first time
because if you have all these notions of
that philosophy
is is just a way of thinking which is
the notion that most people have out
there then that you don't have a
definition that is worth anything okay
love of knowledge is that what the
greeks called it was that how it was
translated what is that what is love of
knowledge that's nothing
some people say that philosophy is not
even a branch of science others say that
it's the mother of science that you need
to have philosophies before you can do
science and so they have all these
versions
so they have no one has any idea what
philosophy is everybody just goes back
to
typically to aristotle who
did a pretty good job of defining it in
in the greek manner or synthesizing what
the greeks thought of philosophy
and so they say yeah philosophy is a way
of thinking that's essentially what
people have in their minds
so it's his philosophy
so we all have a philosophy always all
have a way of thinking we haven't
learned anything by saying philosophy
the only way you can make sense of it if
you
you know
chop it off and put a very
strict
uh specification okay
very strict criteria and say look it's
the uh
explanation of behavior so you could put
in there history you can put in their
psychology you can put their almost
anything uh anthropology
why someone does something
okay why that person behaves the way he
or she behaves then you can use it
consistently then you can say that's
that's philosophy
and that's distinguished from physics
which is an explanation of mechanisms
physical interpretations okay so now we
have a distinction now we can use the
word philosophy correctly
you can use the word physics correctly
and they both fall under
science which is rational explanations
broadly in general
okay okay why do we start with
philosophy today because
we have this issue of the concept people
have no idea what a concept is and here
you see it one fellow says
object that which has shape
uh yeah okay we
we see either eye on that one but then
he says concept the change in shape of
an object
the change in shape of an object what
sense does that make
are there static concepts
like distance
what's change in the shape of distance
but
is easy let me give you a hard one i'll
give everybody a hard one for you to
think and break your head this week okay
you want to do homework do homework on
this okay
here it goes
here we have articles pronouns and
conjunctions
are those concepts or physical objects
well hopefully they're concepts okay
we usually refer to words such as these
as concepts
okay so you have a very simple concept
the
or a and these articles there right fat
how about pronouns you have uh what him
they that
conjunctions and or but that
i put one common denominator that uh
which is the word that
uh because you can use it as an article
a pronoun or a conjunction as you see on
the right there
okay so uh what change in shape happened
there according to the swallow
uh the word uh
a for example the article or the word
that
where's where's the change in shape
okay but see in all these cases what you
see in there are examples there on the
right
um
you're you're implying something else
there's a comparison there's a relation
with something else that spoon
meaning you're referring to that one
with respect to something else
so the word that already embodies it's a
concept because embodies two objects one
is tacitly understood because you're
referring to that spoon and not the
other one
or the or
or some some other
spoon or or utensil okay
that is the situation
which is different than the other
situation
he took the books that were sold
not not any book but those specific ones
okay so all these words show that you
are comparing against something okay so
that's why the word um
concept what is a concept concept is a
comparison between it's a relation
between two objects one object is
implied tacitly included
invoked in some way in the word that you
call a concept there's always two
objects involved in every concept no
matter how you look at it certainly
distance certainly direction how can you
have direction without two
for example okay but you know if you
want to break your head uh to see if
test my definition i mean test it i
don't care
come up with whatever you have okay
bring it on
and tell me why
a concept is not a word that involves or
invokes in some way or other implies it
tacitly includes two objects
okay which means that you need to define
the word object before you can define
the word concept because the concept is
two objects okay or involves two objects
okay so someone here tried to define it
as well said concept
an abstract idea
okay uh what's uh abstract
existing as an idea and what is idea a
thought produced by thinking
no you cannot you cannot use the word
idea or the word abstract to define
kansa because essentially they're
they're all synonyms
so no
these people go out there and they look
for definitions that they find and they
just copy paste without analyzing that's
that's where the problem is okay
and here's one felon
and he says the following he says
is the table a concept a static concept
okay and he said why why does he have
doubts he says we reason with atoms
uh-oh
we reason with adams he says the table
is an aggregate of atoms
oh man he's got to run into trouble why
because of this
because it's myriology
and he doesn't understand what muriology
is i guess you know meteorology is what
something is made of
okay uh they have uh several versions or
a couple versions at least one is uh
time slices
and another one is um
uh
you know what
something is made of meaning many atoms
so he's looking at the wrong thing and
that's called muriology okay so this is
where the problem is he said is the
table of static concept we reason with
atoms the table is an aggregate of atoms
no no way that's not what a table is
okay table is not a bunch of atoms
neither is uh air a bunch of atoms
neither is anything a bunch of atoms
bunch of atoms meriology okay and that's
known as religion okay we don't use
meteorology and science that's the
ordinary speech the notion of ordinary
people out there who have very little
brains to analyze these things okay
and then so so he gets into trouble
because he says well all these atoms are
in continuous movement well no kidding
everything in the universe is in
continuous movement no matter what even
if it stands still if the andromeda
galaxy is moving with respect to us
everything here every atom that you
think is static is moving with respect
to the andromeda galaxy so yes
everything in the universe is moving
uh
in this universal movie as i call it
okay there in every frame you have a
different location for every single atom
in the universe there's no way to avoid
it
motion is part of the universe okay
and so yeah you cannot talk about
continuous movement because uh that's
irrelevant totally with the subject
matter at hand the subject matter at
hand is what is an object is it um
something static that has no motion
and so this guy gets tangled in his own
language because he says it's made out
of atoms all atoms move so therefore
since nothing is static then
what we have is no object because the
object is changing its shape as this
other fellow said every second of the
day
and so they get tangled in their own
semantics they go around in circles so
he says in continuous interface with uh
other aggregates of atoms which can be
on the floor
uh
static or dynamic concept bar object
again he's thinking the floor is made
out of atoms all atoms move therefore
the floor is moving therefore it's not
static etcetera etcetera and then he
says in the air that surrounds it static
or dynamic concept or object
air is always static air is a static
concept
i'm sorry static object okay why because
you can take a cross section of time
okay one
uh frame of the universal movie and in
that frame nothing nothing moves you
have a cross-section of time a
cross-section of motion it's known as
location okay when when you have
location okay what you have is that um
it's a static concept okay so yeah here
you have it here you have air okay
and what is air well air is a static
blob that's all you see there
okay so this all says you know is air an
optical concept the air is constantly
moving all the atoms are moving they're
changing their location with respect to
each other he's looking at many frames
of the
universal movie that's where the problem
is let me get that out of there
and so um so you see the the air inside
a balloon and i'm you only have a few
atoms there okay just to illustrate it
uh
does it bother you that there's a
balloon there i mean you should imagine
this with the balloon completely filled
with air
okay
uh
does the balloon bother you i mean you
say well it's the balloon holding all
the air
because if there were no balloon the air
would what move
that's what people have in the back of
their minds okay
and so let's get rid of the balloon okay
here we get rid of the balloon and we'll
only have the air okay just so the main
simplify things for people okay there we
have it just just the air we got rid of
the balloon you have to imagine
gazillions of
atoms between those
uh air molecules as well okay
and so the question is can we
take a snapshot i mean hopefully we have
colors in this case we're going to color
them green or bluish there
we take a snapshot of that can you take
a snapshot of colored air
yeah and the answer is yes
you
color code the air okay and we'll call
that air okay we take a snapshot of that
now you have a photograph
okay now it's not moving and not inside
the photograph it's not
do you have a shape there
any answer is yes
and it's a standalone shape
we you know we we can take a blob of air
maybe even easier to imagine a blob of
water as i say take it into outer space
in in a balloon pop the balloon
and suddenly this thing rushes out
you take your camera or the astronaut
takes this camera takes a snapshot of
that click
now he looks at the
at the picture
what does he what will it show
it'll show a blob a static blob
does that static blob have shape that's
the million dollar question and if it
does well then you have that thing that
you're calling water that thing that
you're calling air whatever you you took
a picture of it's static and it's a
physical object
anything made out of atoms hopefully is
a physical object okay all you have to
do if you don't believe me just go out
there get your camera take a snapshot of
water
and see what comes out see if it's
moving inside your picture your static
picture
if it ain't moving
what's it not and you see a shape there
then you have a
a thing
and people say well it takes the the
shape of the container
who cares
it doesn't matter i don't care what
shape it takes we're not talking about
what is the shape of water what is the
shape of air
or of gas or anything we're saying does
it have shape
and hopefully a bunch of atoms meriology
okay
when you take a snapshot of that
hopefully
that uh has shape
and it's not moving in a snapshot
hopefully it's not moving inside the
picture okay because if it does maybe
you drank too much
so that's the issue
okay so here we go back to concept okay
we need to settle this thing about
concept because people are having big
trouble understanding what a concept
then distinguishing them from objects
okay so if el says you said what is a
concept yeah correct and i asked that
question i answered two objects well he
he put that
shorter version okay two objects it says
no maybe a relationship between two
objects
the problem is you cannot define it
using the word relationship because
relationship is a synonym
of concept so you can't use the words
relationship to define the word concept
because you're saying the same thing
okay so we say concept let's get it
right okay concept a word that invokes
or embodies two objects or implies two
objects or you know
tacitly includes or whatever however you
want to see it
we need two objects to define the word
object because any content the word
concept because every concept
already contains within that concept it
implies in some way that there are two
objects it's a relation between two
objects that's what a concept is
nobody ever figured that out okay
okay so because they never figured it
out they never were able to tell us the
difference between an object and a
concept and a lot of people still to
this they have problems distinguishing
between concepts and objects some people
think that energy is an object some
people think that love is an object
and when you ask them what is is god a
concept or an object
and that's when they run into a lot of
trouble they don't they don't know if
they're praying to a concept or to an
object to a thing i mean is god a thing
like a man or whatever or he's got a
love
intelligence you know energy
what is love what is god
okay so uh here we have uh file says the
relationships have shape do
relationships have to say and he
answered he answers right yes okay that
is why relational databases
that is why relational databases and
non-relational
databases have different architectures
see this fellow
the fact that you you use a computer and
you do programming for example and they
program these objects as they call them
and they move these objects around
well some of them are objects but not
all of them those which have shape are
objects but
you know relationships are
comparisons between two objects the
relationship itself
is a concept
and he says well there are relationships
that have architecture
yeah please draw a relationship for me i
want to see a relationship
well i want to see the architecture of a
relationship okay and this is where the
problem is these people think that you
know because uh in computer in a
computer world
we can do a lot of these abstractions
and give them names such as objects or
call them architectures or whatever he
thinks you're dealing with objects with
things
not so in physics physics is something
different because it you need real
objects object which
meaning that which has shape that's what
you're talking about and relationships
uh
please draw it for me okay i want to see
a relation take a snapshot of a
relationship yeah i don't know what
you're referring to
and certainly not out of uh
what is it out of the
the computer world the programming world
you can't use any of that in physics
okay
and again it's because people have in
this day and age of services and so on a
lot of people do computer work
programming database uh data entry etc
and they think they're dealing with
things
you know they put a number in there that
says i put a thing in there i put an
object i put a you know an entity or
whatever no a number is not
an object
the object you can say the number five
has shape yeah number five has shape
meaning you know that thing that you put
in there that has shape
but you can't say that's a five because
five the word five has some other
meaning
so you can't say a five has shape
no fives don't have shape because five
means something else
okay
that thing that you had put there with
that
little kernigew
that's not
that's not an object well that is an
object but that's not a five
okay that's an s or
whatever you want to call it but that
thing there is not a five five means
something else five is a concept
and so people confuse objects with
concepts okay
paul says objective collection of matter
again you get into muriology okay
matter what is matter you look it up
many objects that's what it is that's
what matter means many objects existing
objects actually and so yeah it's
meteorology it's religion that's all
you're talking about
okay
uh fall also tries to define other words
in there okay
space boundless 3d extent
okay you look up extent it's a verb
that's what extent means means to extend
so there's no physical object called
extent okay so you can't say that extent
is three-dimensional
and there's no such thing as a
three-dimensional extent because you're
saying that there's a three-dimensional
verb it's like saying that running is
three-dimensional that's what he said
there
and then
no no object is boundless okay so
space is not an object because
if if it's in if it's boundless uh it's
not uh an object all objects are bounded
finite okay that's what object is it's a
synonym of finite and so if it's
boundless you're not talking about an
object what's the object doing growing
why can't you see the outer shape of it
you know the only way to tell me what
space is by if it's a thing if it's a
container then you have to point to it
and for that you got to show me
not only the shape of space but you got
to show me what's providing backdrop the
background to space that gives it shape
that there's a contrast
so unless you can do that uh you know
space is not an object okay
and much less if it's the extent the
extended extending something extending i
guess boundless extension
for sure that's just a verb
you're saying that a balloon is growing
that's all you said and you can't see
the outside of balloon you can't tell me
if the balloon is cubic it's uh
roundish triangular you can't tell me
what the shape of space is
what is motion he says it's change you
look up change it's motion great
what is time it's an interval what's
interval it's a time
what does exist reality what's reality
exist
so uh this fellow just copied and pasted
a bunch of synonyms which is what they
have in ordinary speech and in
mathematics and he put them on here
online uh thinking that he did a great
job you know he put no brain power into
this at all
all he did was copy paste and say this
is what it is this is what's through
tradition this is what we all think it
is democracy everybody voted for this
it's worthless work is nonsense not
useful at all
okay
so uh this is you can say the synthesis
of that uh questions that we need to
answer today keep these in mind when we
go
into this multiverse because
we're gonna try to find out really what
space is this is what the
issue with the multiverse is what is
space
is it a thing okay is it concept okay
if that thing uh is is it finite or
infinite like this guy says uh boundless
boundless extent
this is a monster is extent but if it's
boundless for sure it's not an object
because all objects are balanced okay
finite
is basic container
i mean you know um
let's say they put you in a container
such as a jail a prison
can you get out well yeah maybe you
drill a hole through the wall and you
get out of prison
is that what space is
a container that you can get out of
because there's
something on the other side of it
providing contour con
contrast
back background
background is that what space is
and then the question is if it's a thing
did god big bang whatever create this
thingy called space
where was he standing where was god
standing outside of space created space
out there in front of him or whatever
is god outside of space can there be
anything outside of space because space
is finite
or a space boundless meaning nothing
is outside of it because nothing is
space itself
okay so the the issue here is we need to
answer what space is why because we're
going to try to figure out what
separates one universe from another
which is the notion we have of the
multiverse okay that's that's going to
be the issue okay
so let's get into the subject matter
today and that's the multiverse here we
go okay and a fella starts out by
putting a comment he put it i think
today okay and he says the following
says let's start with universe okay
this comes from universes okay we don't
care about the etymology okay
but he says it means turned into one
okay so universe means one essentially
uni okay
and multiverse means more than one
turned into many
okay essentially that's his reasoning
okay so far so good so we're saying
universe is one multiverse means many
okay many universes
i know you are going to say that
universe equals one thread and there you
see the threads that i'm saying that all
matter is made of okay
uh many verses or many universes equal
many threads okay and i put two there so
we can say that maybe you have one set
of objects that are made from one thread
and you have the other set of objects
unconnected to our universe our
uh bunch of matter
uh made of a different thread okay and
it's twirling somewhere else
okay
but what's the issue here the the
important issue here is what the black
stuff is because when we use the word
universe we're saying that it's matter
and space
okay so we have matter and space but
here are these two universes okay these
two threads
they share the same universe the same
space i'm sorry the same space
okay so are these two different
universes or are they like the uh
galaxies
that are just far apart
but the galaxies are connected in this
case these two universes
are these two chunks of matter we could
say are not connected
okay but so they're twirling around and
you have all this matter made of this
these threads right but they're just not
connected but even if they're not
connected
they share the same space that's the
issue and if universe includes the word
space
then these are not two universes no
matter how you look at it
if if the word universe embodies
includes right the word space if
if it has to include that word then we
do not have more than one universe there
is no such monster as a multi-universe
there can only be two chunks of matter
two threads you can say for example in
this case to talk intelligently and
within each one of these
threads you have galaxies which are very
far apart but they're all physically
interconnected
okay
so he says but what about superimposing
many threads in space
so he's saying that what happens when
all these threads you have these two
threads and let's assume they
superimposed okay
and the question here is that or the
issue here is that you know this is an
irrelevant matter
because we're trying to find out uh the
multiverse and he's saying what if they
uh all these threads get tangled or they
mix with each other go through each
other whatever what about that
it's got nothing to do with the word
multiverse and the issue here is the
following that i
you know i'll answer with a question or
a couple questions did you ask that
question in the context of particles i
mean people say oh bill so many threads
well how about so many particles
and all these threads they go through
each other
and all the particles go through each
other
they occupy the same space
so to speak same time
so so the question you should ask
yourself is don't ask
what your country can do for you that's
what you can do for your country
you know don't ask me about the thread
ask the question to the guy who proposes
particles i mean if you have another
proposal you say well i don't believe in
particles i don't believe in threads i
don't believe in waves
you know what what do you believe in
what's your proposal what's your
assumption
and whatever assumption you have i'm
going to ask you the same question how
many are there
of these thingies that you're proposing
do they go through each other can they
occupy the same space
so no matter how you twist and turn it
we're going to have the same questions i
don't care if you talk about particles
waves threads
you're going to have the same questions
are there so many
yes or no and
how do they go through each other do
they go through each other if not
uh explain how this universe works
so this is the issue okay so
you know by saying or by raising the
issue of how many
and how things go through each other you
get the same question with particles
with
threads with uh
what is it
strings in string theory which are just
particles
string theory is a particle theory okay
talks about locations
and as always you know locations are
filled with nothing
so
yeah
you got the same questions no matter
where what proposal you propose what
theory you have
okay so here we have um
um
a couple fellows uh and they discussed
the
multiverse and so we're just gonna take
with them okay because one guy proposes
the multiverse he calls himself a
physicist
and the other guy proposes that there is
no such thing as the multiverse and he
calls himself a physicist turns out
neither one are physicists they're just
mathematicians okay and
they don't even follow the scientific
method they follow the mathematical
method and that's why they run around in
circles and people think that these
people are geniuses because they do a
lot of math but it turns out that all
the explanations they give and all the
arguments they propose are totally
irrational so let's go with the first
one father's name is siegel okay ethan
siegel and the guy's going to challenge
him is adam frank
okay and so first guy seagull there says
is the multiverse uh real and yeah and
he's gonna say yes the other guy's gonna
say no
and so they say two astro
mathematicians debate
and then you see two notions of the
multiverse you see all these balloons
there or balls
in both cases the one on top the other
one on the bottom on the left right
there and this is the notion they have
and the only thing i want you to focus
on especially on the one on the bottom
which is a little clearer is i need to
know what that black stuff is that
separates all these balls all these
balloons
so i want you to concentrate on the
black stuff that's going to be the key
issue today
okay so let's
move along here okay
siegel the first guy you know he goes
and he does this
he says this is how he justifies the
multiverse he says in the beginning
there was energy
well
there was energy
uh how did he what is energy and how did
it get there that's what he's got to
explain but he doesn't he just goes in
there he says in the beginning there was
energy okay so
he just starts out with something
whatever this energy thingy is okay
and he says energy uh causes the
universe to expand
well uh what is the universe i mean how
does the energy cause the universe to
expand if the universe includes this
energy
and and what gives shape to the energy
if the energy causes the universe to
expand meaning there's this balloon
energy is
inflating somehow is that what the
universe is a balloon or a ball of some
kind that energy pushes it outwards this
is the notion these people have this is
what they ended up with in the 21st
century
okay so he says the universe fills with
matter and radiation okay in other words
this energy converts into particles
okay this is his reasoning
how a concept called energy turns into a
solid thing called particle we don't
know no mechanism and you don't have to
worry about that anyways because it
turns out the particle is not a particle
as he suggests it is no the particles
are uh
equations uh wave function collapses
that's what these particles are
so-called particles they're not
corpuscles like newton would have
thought of them okay so we're not
talking about a little ball a little
dust
grain of sand or a
dust a piece of dust you know we're
talking about just equations so the
energy which is an equation turns into
another equation that's all you said so
far
okay but he says imagine ripples
regenerated by a ball dropped into a
pond okay there we see the uh image on
the right and imagine that okay
if the ball rolls uh
faster than the ripples propagate then
inflation ends and we have a single
universe all we have is one universe
okay great if the ripples propagate
faster than the ball rolls then we have
the multiverse and this is his reasoning
this is if you can call it reasoning
right
okay and by the way this fellow you know
he's uh trying to become popular he
wants to hit it big in the
not in the physics world he wants to hit
it big in the celebrity world he wants
to be like all these other you know
brian greene and degrasse and all these
other people he wants to make money so
he's not a physicist he's just
a guy who uses mathematics to see if he
can get uh to be a celebrity that's
that's his whole entire goal so he
dresses up for fancy in a fancy way so
that people notice him you know like
bill nye you know the
uh
the math magician guy
they all just want to be celebrities
that's it they don't deal with physics
at all and so they give these
uh
uh
common physical interpretations that
people are used to big bang black hole
dark matter and so on particle two
places at once and with that they want
to see if they can you know hit the big
time that's all they're doing okay so uh
here's uh here's the other fellow this
is adam frank and he says there is no
empirical scientific what evidence
for the multiverse so his criticism is
not
that uh what siegel said is
irrational he's saying we have no
evidence so he thinks the prosecutor has
to show the jury
you know the multiverse in some shape or
form you know that
he says look here's the universe now we
have proof we have evidence
that's his notion that's that's what he
criticized and he says
in scientific theories the multiverse
appears as a bug rather than as a
feature we should squash it
so his notion is not that it's
irrational he says it's just uh we have
no way of proving it so
what kind of theory is that where you
say or assumption is that
you cannot verify in any way
that's his that's his uh
rebuttal that's his complaint
okay so neither one as far as i'm
concerned did any good job on this but
they're considered big celebrities you
know they got these big names because
they want to hit the big time they're
they're not into physics they're into
mathematics and worse than that they're
into being celebrities that's all they
care about
okay and so um
this is a rundown okay this is going to
be my reasoning
siegel and uh frank they're just math
magicians they're not physicists
astrophysicists or any of that okay a
physicist is a guy who can explain a
mechanism he's got to explain gravity
that's what he's got to do that's what
siegel and frank have to do if that's
what they do if that's what if they're
astrophysicists okay you specialize in
uh physics related to astronomy right
then that's what you gotta explain you
gotta explain stuff like you know why
does the earth go around the sun and
does not spontaneously exit the solar
system that's what you got to explain
and to say that you're a
astronomer
meaning a physicist and you cannot
explain that which is
very simple
you know you cannot physically give me a
physical interpretation of why the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system or
out of the universe for that matter then
what kind of astrophysicist are you what
do you do you know what do you do for a
living and just equations
okay and uh so if they're mathematicians
okay the majority of mathematicians i
would say over 50 percent uh believe in
the multiverse
maybe i'm wrong okay that's that's my
impression i would say close to 50 or
maybe more than 50 believe percent
believe in the multiverse that there are
more than one universe out there
so what do they mean by that well uh
what is a multiverse multiple universes
as we just said okay okay right
uh what is the universe according to
mathematics
well according to them it's space time
matter and energy all those put together
that's that's what makes up the
so-called universe
in mathematics this is their notion of
universe okay and so you look it up and
i think this comes from the wikipedia
all of space and time and all
other forms of matter and energy that's
where it comes from so i think you can
look it up at the wikipedia you'll find
those specific four words space time
matter and energy that comprises what
they call universe the important word
there is the word space okay i want you
to focus on the word space
and you'll see why because we need to
know what separates one universe from
another in the so-called multiverse
hopefully it ain't space because space
is part of universe
okay we got the idea here
so what separates universe one from
universe two
well the mathematical answer is space
but i thought you said space
is part of the word universe
so if you said universe is equal to
space time matter and energy meaning
space right and now you're gonna say
what separates universe one from
universe two and you say space again
well you got a problem because what is
this is different kind of space
uh has a different flavor a different
smell
what's what's different about this space
that separates the two universes that
include space
that's the question
okay and so what was space well the
boundless 3d extent that's the
definition that this fellow earlier said
and that comes from the wikipedia again
these people just copy paste that you'll
find in the wikipedia so space is the
boundless meaning infinite right 3d
right what verb
great
great definition yeah it's the extended
extent
okay great
and uh
in physics you know extent is a verb
to extend and in mathematics uh space
ends up being a 3d verb
so that's that's what we learned from
mathematics okay so i want you to follow
through uh
understand what the argument against
that the rebuttal is okay so here we
have mr siegel okay and this is the way
they draw it in his uh article i guess
he approved it okay so he had an artist
draw it i want you to focus on what
separates these universes because that's
the key issue what separates the
universes and this is what it shows this
shows this
these black universes with some streaks
there he's showing there the
expansion of the the big bang expansion
in each one of these and what are all
these universes separated by
well they're separated by some green
stuff some halo there some smoke or
whatever
and that's the key issue the key issue
is what's that green stuff
forget about the the universes i want to
know what what the green stuff is i want
you to identify the green stuff and he
says here or this is the caption there
it says regions where inflation ends
shown as the baby universes here are
always what separated by what a much
more rapidly expanding sea of what
inflating space
so what are these universes separate
which contains space that black stuff
inside them what are they separated by
they're separated by more space
so it looks to me that maybe what we
should do is just do it the correct way
and let's get rid of the green stuff
because that's space here it is this is
what they should have shown
okay this is the way you should draw
that in which case uh and again
those arrows
indicate motion
okay but all you have here is matter
separated from matter by what well there
there's distance between them and that
distance we call space that black stuff
there that's the way it should be drawn
okay so why don't they illustrate it
like that because if you illustrate it
like that then you don't have
multi-universes
because you cannot have multi-universes
okay all you can say is that they're
chunks of matter
and the only issue there is whether that
those chunks of matter are connect
physically connected like in the theory
of uh
in thread theory in the rope model
or whether they're not connected if you
assume particles for example if you
assume that all these are just particles
okay made out of atoms within each one
of those and there's this big distance
between one lump of particles like
galaxies for example that are separated
from other galaxies well those are
universes that's how it is what are
galaxies just island universes you can
say and the only issue there is whether
they're connected or not are they
physically connected
well hopefully if the andromeda galaxy
is coming towards us and ours towards
them and we pull on them and they pull
on us hopefully that's done through some
kind of physical mediator that extends
from there to here from here to there
otherwise
why are we
pulling
on andromeda why is it coming towards us
why is it drifting towards
the milky way
why doesn't the earth fly away why does
it roll around the sun continuously what
keeps it
bound to the sun
magic are we going to say mass is it
gravity is that what it is these
concepts
no hopefully it's a physical object that
prevents the earth from flying away
okay and
why doesn't the earth slow down and flo
fall towards the sun
well maybe just maybe it's because space
is nothing
and so the earth has nothing to
rub its uh shoulder or its elbow against
when it goes around the sun that's why
it doesn't slow down
because there's nothing
literally
to slow it down meaning there's only
space and space is nothing
so now we have a rational explanation
why the earth doesn't slow down but to
say that mass pulls on the earth and the
earth doesn't fly up because of gravity
oh you're putting his concepts there you
don't have a physical interpretation you
cannot tell me the cause
okay siegel here uh again he this is a
different version and again he's got all
these universes out there he's got some
blue
i don't know medium there uh it looks
like these balls are on a table and then
there's some
green bluish green
medium there that separates them
it turns out that blue medium
is space and what's inside of each one
of these globes is also space you know
perhaps uh seagulls should have done it
like this
maybe that's the way they should have
drawn it so that you are not confused
into thinking that one chunk of matter
one blob of matter okay
uh
is isolated from another blob of matter
because they all have the same shape
uh the same space they share the same
space
okay so the issue here is what's the
blue stuff that's what you got or in
this case right uh what's that that
bluish stuff that
keeps these uh universes apart because
if space is what's going to be
between
the particles or the
the things that form one uh ball there
what's outside of it more space and if
there's more space there is no
difference between one universe and the
other you cannot talk about universes
it's a single universe because it's one
space whatever space is
and if you say that space is a thing
well you got a problem because now you
got to tell me what's outside of space
giving it
contour meaning it turns it into a um
is it
into a
container
and if it's a container it means it's
got walls and something outside of those
walls you can escape through that
container to some other place maybe to
meet god or whoever who made that
container
so this is the issue the issue has to do
with space and i like really salvador
dali's version of this and here it is
that's more or less what these people
are doing something so realistic
okay they're saying that all these
universes are separated you know from
each other and what you're going to
identify is that bluish
greenish stuff that separates all these
balls that's the key issue because if
each one of those balls contains space
then there is no difference between that
space which is colored differently from
the space that separates each ball
that's the key issue
okay so uh
so here's the uh the notion that they
have to dispel okay let me illustrate
for
last time here it is okay what you got
to identify is the black stuff okay if
each one of these universal expanding
universes since the big bang
is is a separate universe separate
separated from the other universe us and
them so to speak right
uh we need to identify the black stuff
and if the black stuff is is what
separates each one of those galaxies and
uh stars and planets that is each in
each one of those universes
then there is no difference between
these two so-called universes there is
no us in them because us and them share
the same space which is where all this
matter is uh trapped in and it's trapped
forever because if space is nothing
meaning it has no shape then none of
this matter can escape
uh this uh so-called space this
nothingness how do you escape
nothingness if it doesn't have a border
because the definition of space is that
which has no shape
okay so not even god if god exists right
if you want to postulate god no problem
but uh if you postulate god you know god
cannot and you and possibly god is a
thing
you know god cannot leave space because
space has no boundaries
where's god gonna go
how can he escape that which has no
boundaries
that which has no shape that which has
no borders no fence
that which is not a container
so those who don't like my definition
that which has no shape for space right
uh they don't like that definition hey
start by def defining what space is
meaning what nothing is a thing that
which has shape
nothing that which doesn't have shape
now we can use these words consistently
in a dissertation if you're gonna go out
there and say well i don't like your
definition great i don't care
don't like my definition don't vote for
it give me your definition defend it and
see if you can um use it to explain you
know the
how the universe works
okay
okay uh we also had um
follow uh well we had all these fouls um
that dealt with the
what i call the moonies people who think
that
uh
we have not gone to the moon that we
that humans never landed on the moon
and i try to focus them on the iss the
international space station why do i do
that well i do that because
that's something we can all verify for
those who want verification proof
evidence okay take your telescope take
your pair of binoculars find out what
the route is uh the
nasa does uh publish
the route for the iss it's a big monster
out there was built uh over a 10-year
period they built it piece by piece they
could not build it in one shot and throw
it up there with a couple rockets they
were built step by step they built this
monster where people can live in there
lots of people don't believe this they
say well that's not true okay no problem
but then what is that thing that's out
there and they say well it's not there
i don't believe it's there
i'm not asking you to believe i'm asking
you to take your binoculars and point
your point them at the sky
when this thing goes over the earth when
it orbits the earth and see if there's
something there
don't tell me you don't believe in it
because that's like like galileo when he
said we'd ask the cardinals to look
through his telescope and he says i
i i want you i want you to look through
the telescope to see if you see the
galilean moons
and it turns out that they say no i
won't i won't look through your
telescope it's a
a product of the devil
so they didn't look and so they said no
there are no galilean moons because the
bible doesn't mention them and these
people are doing the same thing with the
iss i don't want you to tell me that you
don't believe that the uh you know that
the the
iss is not out there tell me tell me if
you can see it with your telescope with
your pair of binoculars okay there is
something orbiting out there and people
want to skip that stuff and go directly
to apollo 11 1969 right
and here's one fella and he says the
following he says uh apollo lunar
television camera this is what i showed
the other day okay it says as it was
mounted on the side of the apollo 11
lunar module when it telecasted neil
armstrong one small step and there's the
link okay
and this file says did anyone look at
the module to see if there is any
evidence a camera was attached to it are
we just trusting in their word
okay so so again uh these people should
not be talking about the moon landings
because that's beyond
right now you know you can say that any
of this anything that they did in space
could have been done
at least with today's technology right
let's go into best case scenario okay
today's technology maybe in hollywood
you can probably produce all the special
effects that you can imagine okay so
you're never gonna be able to show
uh or or argue that there's a difference
between the real stuff and the one
produced in hollywood there's no way you
can distinguish because everybody
who you say well you know
where was the camera and then you say
well it was mounted on the module and
they said well did anyone prove it well
no you can go on and on and on and on
never reach a solution because you can
argue that this was filmed in hollywood
and filmed by someone else
and yeah you could have done that no
doubt about it and so what what have you
proven with that all you're saying is
that you can do the same thing in
hollywood yeah that's great and
does that prove in any way or is that
evidence or or is that an argument to
show that we never went to the moon
no the way you do it is with something
which is more closer to home which is
look up with your binoculars tell me if
there's an iss rolling around the earth
i mean is there something out there or
not yeah what kind of flat earther are
you do the iss first it's it's more
closer to whom that you can you know
kind of verify for yourself okay
and i'm on record i'm i've said i
haven't seen the iss up there
and i haven't seen
santa claus at the north pole either
okay i'm not going to go to the north
pole to find out if
santa is there
because i'm afraid i may really find
them
and likewise i'm not going to look up
there to see if the iss is rolling
around there's a lot of amateurs on
earth that say they saw it that they
filmed it that they looked at
the iss through their binoculars
and i don't think all those were paid
off by nasa or any of the other world
organizations i'm convinced the iss is
up there okay
okay and again i don't i make that
assumption without
with flying colors you know i i have no
doubts about the iss okay you say you
haven't proved it bill i don't have to i
just make the assumption yeah yes this
is out there okay you don't believe it
you do you do the work you go to the
north pole and find out if
santa claus is there okay
okay and then another fella says
you want proof
uh-huh yeah i want proof evidence fact
okay just take a look at the picture of
the earth they allegedly took on the way
to the moon uh-huh the earth is covered
with one cloud
and i don't know if that was the picture
i don't know what this guy's referring
to he says one cloud earth covered with
one cloud is impossible just go and take
a look
this is the evidence they have
and again uh you know they they get
involved into stuff without taking care
of uh basic stuff like is the iss out
there tell me first if the iss is out
there let's work on something we can all
deal with which is the iss something
everyone with their binoculars with
their telescopes can prove to themselves
and that's where we should start another
fellow says talking about the van allen
belts he says uh
solar van ellen and cosm
and cosmic radiation will fry anything
that travels past the earth
magnetosphere okay especially uh modern
day microchips with smaller transistors
okay so he thinks that because the
transistors are smaller you know that
they're going to fry faster than the
ones the monsters i used to work with in
in the 70s and 80s
not sure that's true because you know uh
you can fry a chip
even uh today you know uh they built
them in such a way that there's they
have this vertical integration we had
more horizontal uh
integration but yeah you get to a point
where uh
the
geometries in a chip are closer and
closer together and they still work and
they still dissipate heat they find ways
of isolating the uh
the transistors and all the other stuff
they have in them so
you know i'm not sure they that they
would fry but this was the first
astronaut to try to venture into outer
space were seeing sparks in their heads
uh they were dizzy you know so it
couldn't have happened right and so you
should
need about six feet of lead to shield
from this
this is what these people believe and
again i'm saying uh you know they're
what can you say and here's another
along the same lines he says the iss is
only 400 000 kilometers above uh 400
kilometers above the surface the van
allen belt is about a thousand
kilometers above the surface okay the
iss is orbiting rather in a very safe
zone around the earth and there you see
i put the iss there if you can see a
little guy there and yeah it's closer to
the earth okay so what have we proved
with this i mean if the iss is out there
i don't care what's rolling is there an
iss out there or not
okay yeah and again the question is
is there a monster that you can verify
with your for yourself you know that you
don't depend on nasa you know giving you
all this fake news
take your binocular and see if there's
this monster up there i'm glad they put
the uh
the iss into orbit because that's
something everybody can more or less
prove to themselves you know those
people who require evidence there you
can do it okay use it use your
binoculars find it okay if you see this
monster if you can see it with your
telescope or your
binoculars
obviously it's a monster out there you
can i mean if you know a little bit of
math you can calculate the distance how
big it is how much mass and all that
stuff you can calculate at all if you
you're not mathematically
savvy you know you can always ask a
mathematician to calculate that for you
so just get the numbers calculated and
you'll find out how big that monster is
which is orbiting the earth made by man
hopefully uh it wasn't the uh
ets that put it into orbit okay and if
there's this monster rolling around the
earth tell me how it got up there
okay forget about the moon landings
that's beyond your
intelligence quotient okay
let's work on something easy that you
can more or less verify put your finger
on okay and that's going to be the iss
okay and another fellow also here says
uh on jumping it is not only about the
gravity but also the consideration of uh
inertia accelerating the mass for each
jump
because he said a fellow that answered
uh you know he says all this jumping the
way the reason they could jump on the
moon is you know
or that they couldn't jump fat higher or
whatever he said they're carrying like
300 pounds or 300 kilograms of
weight
so yeah you can jump six times as much
or not even that much on the moon you
can jump a little higher than you jump
here on earth
uh but you don't have escape velocity
it's not like you jump and you fly into
outer space okay it's not
there's still some gravity on the moon
but now put yourself you know some some
backpack with a lot of weights
and you won't jump as much as without it
that's that was his point and so
you know jumping you can jump a little
easier but now with a lot of stuff on
your back and these guys carry a lot of
weight on their back just in in you know
the backpack that they carry which
carries their oxygen etc etc you know
they have a lot of stuff in that suit
okay so it's not so easy to jump with
that miracle if you jump like that and
again as you can see the guy's jumping
and you know i put it a couple weeks ago
i think
where um
this
if if you do it twice as fast if you if
you run this uh slow motion thing twice
as fast it's like jumping in a like if
they did it in hollywood the guy just
jumps around and they just slow it down
and that's what you see there
what am i saying with that i'm saying
that you would not be able to tell the
difference between hollywood and the
real thing
what have you proven with that what
what have you what's your argument
the fact that it could be could have
been done in hollywood does not prove or
does not negate that we did not go to
the moon it just says it could have just
as well have been done in hollywood
that's all you're saying you haven't
said it wasn't done on the moon
okay so let's get the arguments right
the fact that you can do it in hollywood
does not negate
the moon landings
okay
some people did address the iss okay and
one paul says the is footage is filmed
inside a giant
bitter solenoid in the cern facility in
switzerland
uh-huh it's some kind of magnetism they
say they kept them up but we don't even
need to do that like like i'm saying you
could have done maybe in hollywood and
jump around with you know a string why
would they have to do it in switzerland
at the solenoid
i mean you know these people don't don't
have reasoning capabilities
uh they just say things you know you
don't need to go to switzerland you can
go to hollywood you can get all this
filmed in hollywood i showed it the
other day you know
the actress there she was held by
strings and they showed how they did it
so you don't need to go to switzerland
you can do it in in hollywood
all you have shown is that
whatever's on the iss
or whatever was done on the moon could
just as well have been done in hollywood
that does not prove negate et cetera
that it wasn't done on the moon
okay so the argument is false
you know the fact that you can do it
here does not mean it wasn't done over
there that's that's the issue
okay another uh muni here uh
a guy who does not
believe he knows okay let's see what he
knows
so he says uh the monies are not those
who do not bel uh who do not believe
that we went to the moon but people who
know
that man cannot set foot on the moon
and you know all i can say is that no is
equal to believe no means that you know
whatever you know is what i don't know
what i don't believe i don't believe in
your knowledge
so when you know that god exists i know
that god does not exist and when you
believe that god who says i believe that
god doesn't exist so who's right
so there's no such thing as knowledge
knowledge is belief so all you said is
that you believe that man cannot be uh
cannot set foot on the moon you just
believe it that's your belief
okay and then you have this uh
uh he continues he said furthermore
there are people who are convinced
meaning belief right that the earth is
flat and that gravity is simply a
density gradient that there are there is
no space and that neither satellites nor
space deviations can exist
yeah and again we're talking about
belief uh convinced means just belief
means that they believe this they're
convinced of it they know for sure right
and then exists uh has nothing to do
with belief okay in physics we have to
define the word exist okay
and it has absolutely nothing to do with
belief because if we define uh
existence in term of belief like you
know do you believe in the existence of
god do you believe in the existence or
the you do not believe in the existence
of god well how about the existence of
this chair
do you believe in the existence of
this chair
what if you say you don't believe in the
existence of that chair
well you know what what can i do about
if you don't believe i can't help you
believe you know i mean
the chair exists hopefully by definition
not because we believe or stop believing
okay so belief has nothing to do with
the word exist or existence that's why
atheists agnostics and theists run
around in circles when they say well i
believe in the existence of god well i
don't believe in the existence of god
and the other guy says well i don't know
if god exists or not
they're all saying the same thing
they're all saying nonsense the way we
do it in science is we say let us assume
that god exists
and for that for you to understand what
i just said you have to define the word
exist
you can say okay exist physical presence
meaning an object that has location
now we understand what we said
it has it has to be an object
and if it wants to exist if if we're
going to use that word exist then it has
to have location meaning distance with
respect to everything else that exists
okay that's the way that's what the word
means but if you say i don't believe in
the existence i believe and exists i
know that exist that such and such
exists
well you know but i don't know
you believe i don't believe and
what are we gonna do with that
if it depends on belief on personal
opinion
okay so this is the issue
okay and uh here's another fellow and he
brings up the iss the issue of water
okay
and we have this lady this astronaut and
she
releases a drop of water okay and then
she swallows it
and he's upset about this he's offended
by this he says would you let a quantity
of water in a potentially
life-threatening environment
oh my god
uh you know he's saying that releasing
water is so dangerous so dangerous
in the iss that this had to be done in
hollywood there's no way you're going to
do this
in a scientific environment you're not
going to play around up there you know
have fun
it's got to be serious you got to do
everything you know by the book and so
on and you don't want to release a drop
of water why he says if by chance that
water ended up against an electrical
panel
or vital instrument since you are
spinning around the earth 15 times a day
okay instrumental electric installations
are not waterproof the iep is not 67 for
example
my god he thinks that because this thing
the water could you know touch something
in there it's gonna rust or or short
circuit or whatever and they would not
do such a
thing you know he never thought that
some of these things could be isolated
from you know the the controls and all
that
you know what what why are sticking out
there and assuming it's sticking out is
it isolated or not
i mean i worked in an environment where
where we had a lot lots of electronics
the whole place was electronically
crowded
and we dealt with gases with water we
dealt with uh
acids
you know i mean any of that would have
touched some wire inside some of these
machines
you had not only an accident but a very
important accident
everything's isolated i mean this guy
has no idea whatsoever he doesn't even
know what he's talking about
okay but uh he does say something
important which is important which is
interesting he says the point not all
official videos of the iss are fake well
thank god you know i mean maybe someone
really comes down to earth
finally and accepts that you know maybe
just maybe
there's a an iss out there and maybe all
these films are not all
fake
and so let's not worry about the fake
ones maybe that's just for kidding maybe
just to fool the public okay fine
but some of them are real right
if some of them are real let's worry
about the real ones
and let's not worry about the fake ones
certainly there are very suspicious ones
being a
cinematographic reproduction which leads
to suppose for some people that
everything is false yeah i i get that a
lot of people say well this is
suspicious so that's fake
but how about the
real ones let's forget about the fake
ones you know let's deal with the real
ones the one you think are real right it
raises perennial doubt given that the
source of the information has lost its
credibility okay that's again question
of belief credibility okay what people
think is truth what people think they
know
for sure
it's like believing the government is
doing it for us yeah and so again it's a
question of um
credibility
whether you're going to believe
something because they fooled you once
you won't fool me again that sort of
thing
but that doesn't negate whether we went
to the moon or not first let's find out
if the iss is rolling up there if you
think some of the
videos that they show from the iss are
real that the astronaut is actually
floating up there or flying around or or
twirling his uh
laptop or his palm top right if that's
happening
yeah
could it have been done in hollywood
i'm gonna concede i'll just go all the
way i'll say yeah it could have been
done in hollywood
what does that prove
it just proves that what could have been
real or what is real which is what's
happening inside the iss could just as
well be
done in hollywood that's all you're
saying you're not saying that because of
that
that's not real
okay so let's understand the argument
okay the fact that you can prove show
present evidence etc etc etc that it
could have been done in hollywood it
could have been done in a studio does
not negate that that is real and it was
done actually on the iss
okay we got the argument
okay let's go with the uh questions
people asked this week
sorry uh it took so long to come out but
again i
got this problem now my
uh
air passages are crowded
so
i don't know if i'm going to come out of
this
very well i may have asthma for the rest
of my life they've got me sniffing
this poison you know it goes all the way
deep to my
uh bronx
and hopefully it'll unclog them we'll
find out
okay so one file says
says wrong evidence he says how do you
think it works and how it works is not
always correct look at the language he
uses and this is this is how people
think okay you have uh correct the word
wrong evidence proof
he believes in the ether that he has no
problem with that and then he talks
about faith and evidence
no matter what word you choose it's all
this is how people talk
these are normal people who you know
ordinary people out there who know
nothing about physics
they have no no
intuition
of physics and so this is how they talk
and so
you know what kind of language is this
for physics oh this all these are
opinions
has nothing whatsoever to do with
physics so you know it's not worth even
answering this uh individual because
really he makes no point just makes a
declaration based on his beliefs on what
he thinks he knows okay he has no
problem with that
okay here we have another vow he says a
belief has absolutely no credence in
scientific method correct he's
absolutely corrupt truth is believing
yeah
truth is believing that's true
truth is just belief
what it's what's uh truth to you
is just your belief because you are
certain of that truth
you know you're certain that your wife
slept with your neighbor
maybe that's not what happened but you
believe it that's truth to you and
you're going to kill her no matter what
okay so he says a hypothesis is a
justified belief
absolutely not that's not what a
hypothesis is
justified is just an opinion again
justified means you justified it it's
justified to you
you know god is justified to you but not
to your neighbor okay and uh how about
this no it's not a belief it's an
assumption you make an assumption about
something you call that a hypothesis let
us assume let us hypothesize okay a
theory is he says a substantiated
explanation which may not be correct
so he says substantiated but incorrect
okay great could be incorrect and no
substantiated again is opinion belief
religion substantiated means to you
you believe it you it's substantiated to
you it wasn't substantiated to me i
don't accept that substantiation okay
and correct whether it's correct is also
an opinion
it's substantiated to you it's correct
to you not to me or to your neighbor so
again uh the the wording that these
people use to make their case is all uh
opinionated and they don't realize that
they think that because they believe it
so strongly it's the truth it's a fact
it's uh they have evidence
i don't care what evidence you you
produce any evidence you want to me i'll
i'll just play devil's advocate i'll say
no no no no no no no
and what are you going to do
you know and you'll say no but i've
proven it here's the evidence in i
believe it and i know it and
i don't
and what are you gonna do i don't accept
your evidence
okay so no uh there is no such thing as
truth fact
okay
evidence is uh depending on the
uh
person who hears it either believes it
is substantiated to him not to me okay
so none of that has to do with science
okay
it's all belief and he says a fact is
empirically correct again he uses the
word correct okay and fact is what
opinion belief
religion and then he says pseudoscience
is a collection of beliefs mistakenly
regarded as being based on the
scientific method yeah and there's two
examples there one is mathematics the
other one is the electric universe and i
guess you can add to that the
uh what is it the
john chappelle
uh society they're also within that
group it's all pseudoscience because
they think they're following the
scientific method
okay here we have another following he
says the following he says can you
describe the linkage or mechanism which
established and maintains earth's
orientation relative to time while
spinning and orbiting the sun over
millennia
yeah and uh
there it is uh imagine every atom in the
universe is physically interconnected we
connect them with what we call the
electromagnetic rope the same rope
builds these atoms and then on the other
side continues as a rope so they're all
connected in comparison mathematical
physics
uh they use discrete particles there's
no connection between particles and so
the question is how does a one particle
influence another
and you see the problem there with the
question you're asking which is the
how is it that the earth essentially
doesn't fly out of the solar system and
in the case of particles you know how
are you going to explain it i mean
what's between the earth and the sun
well if you put particles in there how
would those particles prevent the earth
from flying out of the solar system on
the other hand with the uh
interconnectivity physical
interconnectivity what you have there is
the earth being bound every atom of the
earth being bound to every atom of the
sun and now you can see why the earth
perpetually goes around the sun okay
um
always at the same rate more or less why
because it doesn't uh rub against space
there is no friction between the earth
and the sun
so
you know this hopefully answers your
question there is a physical
connection between the earth in fact
every one of us and the sun
okay and here we have another follow and
he says the following says when a human
sees and touches something it is defined
as an object
uh not in science but yeah that's the
ordinary notion out there
c-touch refers to can be seen and can be
touched yeah that's what they
that's the ordinary notion okay out
there
if i don't see with my eyes live and if
i don't touch the pen that bill drops on
the table the pen does not exist
so he's got to see it to believe it to
accept it as existed he's going to
believe
in existence okay let's keep that in
mind bill's pen exists because the
evidence is clear he needs evidence for
existence he's saying that's what he's
that's what he's suggesting he needs
evidence for existence okay uh no in
science we define the word existence
before we use it in a sentence
otherwise you can't talk about the
existence of something you have to
define the word exists before you can
use it in a sentence and that's where he
fails he thinks it's got to do with
evidence with belief etcetera etcetera
okay uh
yeah another fellow i think is the same
fact that believe means not to know to
believe a thing means to believe
no kid
that it is true true to whom to the pope
to you to whom
to the atheist to have the certainty
meaning your conviction
that it is just as it appears or as we
have seen been told by others because
you believe it other someone told you
something you believe it that's why you
know you have certainty
yourself
you believe it okay so we're still with
belief here we have an abandoned belief
to believe in something means to accept
it as true yeah for one person for that
person
to know means having knowledge
i love that absolutely no means i have
knowledge yeah
and these people you know
they have no idea how to define words
they never define words in their life
and when you put them against the wall
they say well you're doing semantics
bill you're playing with words
magic words you know
paul says evidence equal belief that abs
but absolutely not okay so evidence is
not just belief okay bill wants us to
accept his belief that having an opinion
is religion yeah
religion is defined as opinion it's not
a belief in god it's opinion when you
have an opinion you have religion okay
that's how it is
or that presenting evidence of an event
that has happened is belief yeah when i
present evidence to a jury
okay or the prosecutor does he is
believing
you're compelling or you're asking the
jury to believe
in the evidence
to interpret it the same way that you
interpreted the evidence and what
evidence are you going to present for
invisible intangible
mediators such as gravity and
electromagnetism what can i present to
the jury what evidence how can i make
them believe
that a rope
or
gazillions of ropes produce gravity if
we cannot see or touch them how can i do
it with particles assuming let's propose
particles no problem
so how can i show them these particles
if you cannot see or touch them how am i
going to present that evidence to the
jury for them to to compel them to
believe okay so this is the issue
okay and thou says
who knows how many and which phenomena
we humans do not perceive both with the
senses again
see touch right and with the mind
thinking
for example an object is because it has
form yeah that's our definition well but
there is no criteria for defining that
it has formed or does not have it
what we need to d distinguish here is we
need to define the word object for the
purposes of physics because we cannot do
physics without an object so what's the
issue here the issue here is that we
either go with the shape and form
notion of object or we go with what we
have now which is see and touch which is
what mathematics do uses
and so the issue there is if we cannot
see or touch the mediators of gravity of
the electromagnetism of the atom and the
for example the proton and the electron
what's in between them then if we don't
have
uh
you know
we cannot see or touch those
then then we're dead because we're never
going to see touch we don't have any
object there because we can't see your
touch and that's the definition that
we're proposing for object then we're
screwed and that's where we are today
because people can't see or touch the
mediators
that produce gravity
electromagnetism etc etc
and so
we cannot continue to define the word
object
on the basis of c touch it's got to be
something else and i'm saying it's got
to be shape because shape is universal
all objects have shape
and i challenge anyone to come up with
an object that does not have shape okay
and here's the last one fella just makes
a comment he says if anyone needs a good
laugh look up fields or magnetic fields
in the wikipedia and here he goes
through the rundown it says field
physics a field is a physical quantity
a physical quantity don't get hit by the
one of these fields these physical
quantities okay my hitch in the head
uh reddit s science it says a magnetic
field seems to be made of what virtual
photons what are virtual means you know
that they don't exist they exist only
when the mathematician waves his magic
wand because he needs it an equate in an
equation so he produces these so-called
photons which immediately you know
recombine and form empty space
another uh source there he says a field
is something that takes on a value at
every point in space and time yeah
that's essentially what it is just
values numbers
electrons come from the electron field
which are numbers right neutrons are a
combination of the up and down quarks
which come from the up and down quark
fields
and then the higgs bosons right come
from a particular part of the higgs
field etc
yeah
all this essentially amounts to a
a laugh it's a it's making fun
of
uh
rationality that's what they're doing
okay before the light turns out
completely i'm out of here we'll see you
next time uh hopefully i'll be in better
shape